e pode sensível já perdeste pode pessoal
aqui quem fala é o lugar que seja muito
bem vindo a mais um vídeo e eu hoje
pessoal traduz daqui uma forma de vocês
passarem vossa quarentena bem créditos e
ainda ganharem algum dinheiro neste
vídeo vamos mostrar cinco truques vocês
podem fazer em casa aos vossos pais aos
amigos são cinco truques quando vocês
podem ganhar de sempre mas sempre algum
dinheiro vendendo vocês gostarem né eu
por exemplo do que estar com os meus
amigos sem euros senhor nesse caso não
vou postar nada vou eu apostar apenas
mas é só para vocês verem como eu nunca
vou perder esse dinheiro porque estas
são cinco aposta onde eu nunca posso
perder nunca a não ser que eles saibam
tipo truque né é para a primeira aposta
vocês só vão precisar de três copos vão
colocar os assim ele para cima e 2 para
baixo e apenas em três movimentos podem
cada movimento tem que mexer dois copos
vocês tem que ter os copos todos para
cima do movimento dois movimentos três
movimentos os cabos são fontes para cima
quem conseguir isto ganha-se
é assim que eles começam assim ó
é difícil não ó
e aí
[Música]
g1
e era um
e não 12 un
oi dois oi hora não pode passar tudo
isso
e 2121
a falar agora
e aí
e eu quero te ver a fazer isto pode ser
possível qualquer eu sei que é
impossível hugo
[Música]
os dois não fizeste batota como assim tu
não criaste bem este fizer haver um
vídeo tem uma carreira e
g1
e aí
em 1231
e não não faz a fazer assim não
produziram para mostrado em
é um olha o que foi que fizeste para ti
um
12 tirar é assim que estás a fazer isso
próximo truque do papel higiênico e vou
pedir para sair assim e o desafio é este
tem que ficar de pé nunca vai dar certo
nunca porque sempre papel assim ó
a distância tanto faz sim
eu não tenho 80 aqui vamos lá
e aí
[Música]
e no novos isso não vais lá tu então
para ver se é
[Música]
um simples vai adiantar hahaha nunca
sabe o
e olha ficou não não vale tudo bem que
está tudo então ó
e isso não é possível pena país que é
possível sim é
e aí
[Música]
eu vou conseguir fazer pa ra ra
eu abro burro hahaha ha
é só gosto assim ó
o next próximo truque para vocês
perderem passaporte o que é partes
precisam de um prato e uma moeda de 100
porcento então era assim mais pequena
tempo mais leve como é que funciona é a
moeda vai estar fora do frágil temos o
prazo e temos a moeda e o vosso familiar
ou você amigo tem que colocar a moeda
dentro do prato sem tocar não é daqui e
no prato é
e sempre carne moída mas isso tem que
regressa sem ficar na moeda e no prato
eu sinto cada uma moeda como no prato
então como é que é suposto mas são boas
mãos após a tipo o nariz não pode usar
nada sem tocar um
a mesa posta
se você tivesse sem tocar na moeda e no
curar você não fala assim não depois tu
não vai dar a superar me descobrir eu
vou descobrir o
e é assim não porque se fosse antônio
peres furno não posso agradar nenhuma
nem com a boca não
a juíza que a mamãe fica louca
e é porque eu preciso esperar muita
força eu sou a volta não dá faz outro
faz tu queres ver o
e me
eu estava perto é isso sem tocar em nada
[Música]
ah tá bem mas tu morresse e
oi para o próximo truque vocês vão
precisar de uma cartolina com a seta e
pode ser uma certa tanto para a esquerda
comprar direita ou para cima ou para
baixo é diferente eu tenho que explicar
de madeira mas serve apenas como suporte
vocês podem usar qualquer coisa e o que
tem que fazer é colocar assim o suporte
e cartolina de frente com nosso amigo ou
familiar para ganhar essa aposta tem que
inverter o sentido da seta sem tocar
neste cartão parece difícil não é bora
lá pessoal para vocês ganharem sempre
esta aposta é muito simples é só colocar
em um copo de água diferente em frente a
seta assim e não sei se dá para ver aí
mas a água inverte o sentido da seta que
não é mesmo é
e sem tocar sem encher sem superar sem
nada então é que com a força do meu
pensamento você não sente carregado
assim fraco sinal eles também
e depois de um copo de água disso hahaha
do espelho ele continua não se ela está
no espelho está virada para o claro que
[Música]
não é um
e não causa de apartamento com 1 copo de
água um copo de água muda tipo
e quantas coisas de maneira diferente
oi mãe como é que eu faço
é mesmo tudo isso não vale a
e pensa mas a cabeça
e se meteram olha aqui a virar para aqui
ela fica para outro lado mas paz
relativa a
e eu não sei se posso aceitar essa eu
acho que todas estás melhor ok fica ver
50 euros lá é porque é possível não está
perdido meus amigos obrigado fazer o
próximo posto
o rock vai vir a última aposta domingo
eles consegue vencer esta assim é muito
complicada eu duvido que alguém consiga
mesmo vencer o que é que vocês precisam
não terraço de madeira com um buraco e
precisam de ter sete pregos iguais
netflix como esses aqui ó inclusive eu
comprei este que isso numa loja de
enigmas imagens mas vocês podem
construir isso em casa eu acho e dessa
aposta tem colocar os três pregos apenas
em cima deste prego só aqui só nesta
superfície aqui do prédio não vale a
madeira não vale nada que só o preco
esta é bem difícil mas fica mais ou
menos assim tão os seus pregos
equilibrados em apenas um prego esta não
vai porque já sabia eu não é
e como é que era sem truques como é que
era não não juro juro juro que fui ao
foi o que a gente acaba não cérebro e
[Música]
g1
a fazer isto pa ter uma coisa
o frango curtindo não me lembro que foi
já teve a fazer isto sozinho não me
lembro como é que era a
ah tá não é sinto com essas ok esta não
parou preocupe já sabia dessa eu não vou
não valeu não valeu pode chegar que eu
tô sentindo que eu estou a chegar a um
objetivo é
e era como assim parece que não faz
sentido pois não tenho outros como
e eu eu lembrei mas eu lembro que quando
explicaste isso ai próximo mas que eu
sei da história deste campeonato que o
senhor é
o de cima não é ei esse tema não é aqui
não não porque tem que ficar febre na
vaza abaixo não pode ser mexido pois
daqui librastudo aqui então se não é
assim não é assim não a ser assim ó
e a senhora tá
o olá eu sou o pi e fui convidado aqui
para participar a aposta dos cem anos
e aí
além disso já tá bom
o olá todos eu sou aqui eu vou ser a
vencedora deste enigmas desta coisa e
vou ganhar estes senhores por isso
fiquem atentos aí a ver ó
é sim olá estou mais calma olá sou a
marta para concorrer aos em euros e